desde la victoria de la revolución
islámica de 1979 Esta es la imagen de
las estudiantes que quería proyectar la
República islámica el velo no solamente
era exigido en las calles en las
oficinas sino también desde muy pequeñas
en las escuelas y estas jóvenes
especialmente colegiadas y
universitarias fueron las primeras que
se rebelaron desde el año pasado después
de ese trágico fallecimiento de esta
joven kurda maxa a mini que murió cuando
después de haber sido detenida por la
policía de la moral por no llevar bien
ese vestir islámico muchas de estas
jóvenes no solamente dentro de los
colegios sino dentro de las
universidades estamos en una de las
calles llamada Revolución donde
transitan todos los días miles de
estudiantes muchas de ellas se quitaron
el velo durante meses haciendo la vista
gorda la policía y las autoridades que
prefirieron no dañar más la estabilidad
y la calma del país después de esas
duras protestas sin embargo esto ha ido
cambiando en las últimas semanas y
especialmente en los últimos dos días
cuando el Ministerio de Educación y de
salud advirtieron a las jóvenes
estudiantes que serán castigadas y no
recibirán beneficios sino llevan bien el
velo esto implica que por ejemplo no
tienen el beneficio de salud
alimentación y muchas de ellas las que
viven en residencia nos han contado
muchas de las estudiantes que cada vez
que entre las universidades tienen que
llevar el pelo si no las apuntan y
muchas de ellas si no cumplen con la
norma Lo que sucede es que no pueden
inscribir sus clases y son retiradas de
la universidad